I'm not sure if you heard about this but
the 2016 election was completely bananas
Trump and Hillary were actually only
part of it as there were other
characters from Bernie and Jeb to Marco
and Ted the election also caused the
implosion of the mainstream media and
set us on a path that has hashtag Magga
racing towards hashtag resistance with
the rest of us caught right in the
middle
Ohio Governor John Kasich was one of the
more moderate voices in a campaign
season that was short on moderation as a
fiscally conservative socially liberal
Republican I see Kasich as someone who
has some of the right ideas but whose
timing just wasn't right for the madness
of 2016
Kasich steam reached out to us a couple
days ago and we have him in studio today
totally unscripted and unedited with no
advanced knowledge of the topics or
questions I think this is exactly the
way we need to be hearing from our
politicians and I hope that this
interview helps deal us in on these
conversations in the near future
[Music]
joining me today is the author of the
new book two paths America divided or
United a former Republican presidential
candidate and the current governor of
the great state of Ohio Governor John
Kasich welcome to the Rubin report
that's a really good television voice
house thank well we were just sitting
here you were kind of normal and that
you were like dude you know it was like
Ted Baxter very good ah Ted Baxter I
like the reference that did not go over
me well you know I like of course
everybody else watching their little he
is but that's okay they could google it
some of my millennial people won't get
it but they should google who Ted Baxter
is that would that would be good for
them so first what I wanted to start
with you I'm incredibly excited you're
here and it's interesting because your
people reached out to us about four days
ago they said the governor would like to
come in and then we quickly set this up
nobody said oh we have to talk about
this or we can't talk about this you sat
down here about two minutes ago and you
said whatever you want to do is fine and
I feel like that is partly what's lost
in politics right now that we're gonna
just do this well it's not just lost in
politics I see it lost in a lot of
things you know I mean I met with this
big car company and like they had these
guys come in to see me and it was like
they were totally scripted and you know
so I think you know life is having fun
life is you know being able to to be
real and the reason why we wanted to do
this is I actually kind of saw part of
one of your shows and this media is
really amazing a lot of people don't get
it and I'm starting to get it and I have
some people around me who say this is
really a way to keep your voice out
there you know that's what I want to be
able to have a constructive positive
voice to help our country and this is
another avenue that i'm glad no one else
has found it yeah in my profession yeah
so we can be a first mover which I I
really I really like and I like the fact
that we can actually have a conversation
longer than just a couple sound bites
yeah do you ever worry that because
we've lost the ability to do this that
the sound bite world is what's causing
so many of the
well that was what happened in a
campaign it was all you know we didn't
do it but these other campaigns and I
had advice from some people who had run
before make sure you get your little
thing out there so you can blow up the
television Morning News and you know and
it's like tricks you know mm-hmm that's
not a good thing and look people I saw I
saw thing on the side yesterday it said
email me please we have to talk yeah I
think the look I I didn't have a
smartphone for a long time I have I've
had an iPad and I got it in the very
beginning but I didn't have a smartphone
and people would laugh at me but I
didn't need this stuff during the day
you know I didn't need to have
basketball scores or look at the weather
25 times or you know some kind of
headline in the news or my emails
because I have people that can you know
tell me if there's a crisis they tell me
I go okay well let's see what it is but
I got my smart phone and now the best
thing about it is that I can text but I
find that when I text you know what it
does is it creates a laziness right you
don't have to go through a conversation
yeah now don't you think
look you have a cup you have a show here
where people talk this is what you think
about it don't you think this is a
problem I mean I think that resetting
our ability to talk and actually think
and and sit across from somebody and
make some eye contact and really try to
understand what they think I think that
is almost the most important thing that
we've given up in these last couple
years it was the trade-off between all
these devices and the immediate response
so what do we do about it
this I mean I honestly think that you
come in here right now and you're people
being brave enough to say yeah it's not
like I have my people you know these are
people that work around yeah kind of
support me and help me they're friends
and but this whole you know sort of
funny we were you go on these shows on
regular television which I think are
really important and you get you know
two million people to see you but if you
are like hanging out with Logan Paul
that's 16 million subscribers it's like
and you know the funny thing about it
is that people can't see it really now
but that's not really true because I
think probably you're in demand now and
you can go out and make talks and people
show up to see you yeah but it's kind of
an invisible world to those who were
kind of hooked on television right you
understand what I mean by that I do so
how do we how do we bridge that I don't
know but you know what's I think it's
called what's news it was really
fantastic and there were a couple of
million views and and I liked it you
just have to keep doing it it's part of
why I wanted to be here
I mean I look you I pull up here you've
got a studio in your garage yeah it's
it's cool it's neat and you know you
don't have to go very far right yes like
commutes about 10:00 you know that way
the hard thing has got to be getting
compelling guests there's got to be a
hard thing to do how do you go about
doing that
well fortunately a lot of people are
coming to this medium now and a lot of
the guests that you asked me right
before we started all these books here I
mean most of the I think well virtually
every single one except the Carl Sagan
but are there any of them that are
interesting there's a lot like they're
very boring and I know there's some
great books there by by many of my
guests from Steven Pinker and Sam Harris
and Scott Adams and yeah plenty of I see
you have one here on John Adams so I
have it we did a president's week a
couple weeks ago John Adams so you're
getting you're getting good over the
cone we're getting was it was it you
know what a lot of times when I am with
the press I'm actually curious about
them and they don't like it when I'm
asking them stuff okay it must have been
hard in the beginning right Owain it's
hard to build anything I mean you know
you know that but I one of the things
that I consistently tell my audience is
it's cool that a lot of the beliefs that
I have you know I fall a little more
within classical liberalism and
libertarianism a lot of the beliefs
about doing things for yourself and I've
built this business with the same ideas
that I try to talk about here
some of which I think we're gonna get to
and it's kind of a beautiful thing not
if I keep not if you keep going yeah all
right let me ask you a couple of
questions as long as you're here so I
thought just first I thought we just a
little bit about growing up what kind of
family you grew up in I feel like people
never do that in politics anymore we go
to immediately what everybody kind of
mocks me because I say my father was a
mailman and so the people write that and
they're like
cynical and all that but
I grew up in a town that was over I mean
I don't think I ever met a Republican
not in my town my Uncle Harry was a
Republican they say we didn't listen
much to him he's a great guy but you
know it was blue-collar and you know is
sort of these some of these people you
would define as kind of the Trump people
you know who felt they've been left
behind so you know as a result of that I
guess I that's why I'm a populist but a
positive populist not a negative
populist positive that we can do it we
can together we can we can rise and
that's a great place to come from
because you really have a sense you have
a sense of people you know and it's not
just the upper crust we respected the
upper crust I can remember saying to my
father one time daddy what about the
rich he said well we don't hate the rich
we want to be the rich you know and so
it was great god-fearing conservative
Democrat good values faith was a was a
part of my early childhood which I
normally drifted away from when I went
to college you know it's like Augustine
he says you know I needed I know I need
to be committed to God but just not
right now I have a couple parties to go
so you know we all drift away and I've
drifted I'm not drifted I've come
roaring back into that but common sense
right
freewheeling sometimes it puts people
off a little bit the way I am because
I'm pretty direct and but the other
thing is I was telling somebody the
other day that you know I don't want
people to be confused about my positions
on anything and so if somebody says well
I think it's blue and I might say well
no I think it's red and they most people
would expect me to say okay well
consider that and I'm like no no I just
don't think that and I think to some
degree people don't get it so it takes a
little bit of time for people to come to
understand me yeah
all right well that's what we're gonna
do here for the next hour oh you
mentioned a couple interesting things
there so you didn't grow up in a
Republican family personnel and you just
use the phrase conservative Democrat
yeah so one of the things I talk a lot
about here is that it seems to me before
we get into your party that the
conservative Democrat or the Blue Dog
Democrat or sort of the moderate down
there a lot of them were buddies of mine
in Congress you know great friends do
they really exist anymore I think this
is I think this young man in
Pennsylvania is Blue Dog Democrat from
what I can see now he got elected at 33
I think I was 30 so he's kind of
old-timer yeah but no I think that I
think in both parties it's really hard
if you're Republican you got to fear the
right and if you're a Democrat you fear
the left and it just pulls everybody
apart you know that though but but
you've managed to kind of work through
something that's sort of centrist right
somehow well I don't know what that
means you know one guy once told me the
only thing that goes down the middle of
a road are yellow lines and dead skunks
okay and I'm I'm not a but I'm a common
sense person well I guess so look I look
at an issue and say okay what do we do
about it and we look at a problem how do
we fix the problem but I'm not really
going to have an ideological force
that's pulling me back but the same time
being a conservative I want to see what
the solutions are without having to
bring bureaucracy or government and and
I'll tell you why that is it's because
government inherently is so subject to
political considerations that people
have a hard time make calling a spade a
spade it's like no no I got all these
pressures and I don't like that and so
when you go to government you can get
trapped but you get trapped with big
business to big business you know you
try to like I need this prescription you
know and somebody out here is telling me
oh no no it costs too much you know big
things like that all have always
bothered me
you know big institutions whether it's
government I grew up my dad was in a
Union I always liked unions but you know
the problem with the unions is when the
union boss is not representing a worker
and so big institutions don't throw me
where am I kind of unpredictable see
because you kind of labeled yourself a
little bit ago you said well I'm this
and that if you ask me what I am I'll
say I'm a conservative but then you will
say well but why do you think this or
that and
because I don't think we need to be
stuck right being stuck in life is
really depressing all right so tell me
about what does being a conservative
basically mean to you then if government
is a last resort yeah not as a first
resort but but I also don't think it's
like no government you know how do you
decide where that's that new user do use
judgment and you listen you have good
people around you think about things and
we're trying to price something right
now in our state somebody wants access
to stuff in our state okay it would it's
a good thing it's a good thing what they
want but I don't know what the price of
the value of it is okay so I can't just
look at what governments have done to
determine the value because I don't have
a you know I don't have a whole lot of I
don't invest a lot in that I want to go
out and talk to a variety of people and
business to say what do you think this
is worth okay and so how do I do that
people that come in and they talk and
they argue for certain things but at the
end I have to decide so I just used as
good a judgement as I can yeah do you
have a certain leeway when it comes to
sort of thinking for yourself as a
governor that maybe the Senators and the
congressmen can't have because they have
to all cannot that you don't have to
come together and work with people know
if they have to do it from with people
outside their state with massively
competing interests and things like that
I was offering budgets against
Republican presidents I mean just do
your job I mean why would you want to be
why would you want to have a television
show where you don't make it real why
would I want to be in politics no matter
where I am and not make it real I mean
what would I be there for it's really
stupid right they mean it there's if
you're not there's a lot of people there
for that well I don't want to be I don't
want to be casting aspersions or judging
them only for me why would you do that I
mean so we had a decision on Medicaid
expansion right in Ohio you know that
you know Medicaid expansion of course
right so I was really Jen Brewer in
Arizona did it which really was
kind of shocking to me but I was really
the first big state big Republican
governor who expand it was it hard no it
was a piece of cake if I'm gonna get
money that's not gonna put me in a
straitjacket from the federal government
if I can use that money to heal to help
heal or helps help to help the mentally
ill so they're not sleeping under a
bridge or living in a jail or if I can
help people who have drug addiction to
get treatment and get off of it if I can
have a lower uninsurance rate why
wouldn't I do that and because people
are gonna yell at me and fight with so
what who cares I mean I care I don't
want them to not I don't want him to be
angst in fact in my State of the State
address I was I made a talk that really
had almost nothing to do with policy it
all had all to do with basically
philosophy and the meaning of life
they say was the only State of the State
speech delivered by Governor in the
history of the world where the name camu
was discussed you know but I and I
didn't mention that because I don't want
to jab anybody in the eye but the
decision to do that to help people it's
just it's such an easy decision do you
find you have a little bit of an extra
freedom right now because you can't run
for re-election i yeah i oh now there's
a lot of talk of 2020 which I want to
end the after viewer look I mean
probably so but I've always been very
independent you know I was a military
reformer I was offering my own budgets
against President Bush I would talk on
corporate welfare reform couldn't find a
Democrat with a searchlight and the
Republicans or any other way no I've
always pretty well felt that you know I
you got to do what you have to do and am
I more free now I may be a little bit
but but I think would change I mean I
don't know what is that I would reverse
I wouldn't say well we're not going to
do this Medicaid thing yeah now if you
got us into a point where we were you
know fiscally at risk I would have to
stop it I've told everybody that but now
I don't really think so but I am having
probably more fun now
you know having a lot of fun yeah I mean
I can tell but I've been having fun you
know I ran for re-election and I and I
never even used the word Obama running
for re-election never talked about it I
just talked about a record and it was
fun and it was positive look here's the
thing
and we all need to know this we all need
to be healers in one way or another we
need to heal our family and our friends
and strangers I'm not that great a guy
okay but I know that that makes sense
and I know that it's right so it's just
a cool thing to think about and that's
why politics is so boring to me because
it's all these all these calculations
and all this crap why don't we just do a
job let's think about how to pull to
pull the country together let's make
sure that we can help people to be
lifted let's not tear somebody down
Elizabeth Warren wants to tear down all
these rich people I don't know why or
Bernie or whatever I work with Bernie it
it's you don't need to tear people down
we need to just build people up and and
put them together yeah did you ever get
into any of those philosophical
discussions with Bernie because the
class war nothing I see I see as
extremely dangerous no I know I know I
wouldn't have a conversation with Bernie
Ben Bernie and I were in the house
together he was you know really kind of
in another orbit they all thought he was
and yet you know the country's kind of
moved towards him and I think a lot of
young people are you know the one thing
that is concerning to me and I have
great faith in the Millennials and Gen
Xers but I'm not sure they understand
the consequences of losing a
representative democracy there seems to
be with some of them some appeal towards
an authoritarian figure of you am i
right on that I think you have me yeah I
haven't studied it but I've got that
sense that's not good or that you know
maybe socialism will work look and a
free enterprise system ichael novak the
great philosopher theologian said that a
free market system that is not under
laid with a set of values is bankrupt so
you have to have values you can't just
be in it to make money there has to be
something else there
where do you think those values come
from oh I think they I think that they
the easy thing to say politically easy
thing to say is they come from mom and
dad and I say to people well where do
you think mom and dad got it from right
well they got it from their parents
where do I think these virtues come from
look if you're a humanist I respect you
okay you wake up every day trying to
figure out how to make the world a
little better place I like that okay but
for me the winds of change the fads can
knock me off my path so I need something
deeper than that so I look to
theologians and I believe that we are we
are a unique form of life greater than
all other life on the earth and I think
that life is given to us by our Creator
then I think our Creator has a character
that we can learn about and that's not
only held by a Christian but also a Jew
and also Muslim we have the same kind of
view of creation and our purpose and
within those values are things like
mercy and justice and compassion and
forgiveness and you know if you play
golf that we should we have to have
Mulligan's in life because we you know I
and the danger of talking about these
things is that people want to say oh
well you don't have great values I
caught you what yeah of course I'm just
a slob on a bus trying to make it
through life you know but I kind of know
what I need to do so I think that these
values and they flow from from our
Creator and I think too much in religion
today which is turned off a lot of young
people I'm actually mentoring a young
man in faith but it's not about all this
judgment we hear it's about hope it's
about human connectedness and that's
appealing to people and it's what I
think is true about faith and virtue
it's not confining it's it's enlarging
it doesn't make you smaller it makes you
bigger and today in religion we see a
lot of forces that are counter
to that and I don't like it yeah well
it's interesting to me because my
audience knows that Thomas Jefferson was
my fav favorite founder and I go to the
Jefferson Memorial often in DC and I try
to read those big plaques and to me
they're as relevant now as they were you
know 200 some odd years ago where he
talked abut you know they talk about a
creator at the same time they're talking
about why church and state have to be
separate sure they know and I think
that's really to the heart of what
you're saying well I think first of all
we don't want the government being
involved in religion we don't want that
we want though in a free society look
freedom means we have to learn to
self-govern and if every time we turn
around this is a big thing about
Facebook now they didn't self govern
right I mean we can pass all these rules
but you know guys like you and me were
met we're born to figure out how to get
around the rules okay right
I mean want to be free that's why we're
both here like what I'm saying is that
you can't you if you're going to have
freedom people have to have
self-restraint and the less
self-restraint we have the more the
government tries to impose things and
the more they impose things the less
freedom we have so I don't want it I
believe that that our our faith system
and again if you're a humanist that's
cool with me that's fine with me because
you're trying to do good every day I
just it can't work for me because I get
to knocked off kilter by the culture
today and the winds of change but with
that system it it it reinforces the
sense of freedom
so it's interesting you've referenced
culture a couple times and one of the
things that seem pretty obvious from an
outside perspective the 2016 election
was that Trump captured the culture good
or bad he captured that he captured the
internet culture the reason that your
that can by law and I was like 80,000
votes so we have to keep it in
perspective and the trouble is but he's
a negative populist I'm a positive
populist the people that I grew up with
when they're out of work or whatever my
message is this is terrible but let's go
fix it I think the negative populist
message is well you're out of work
because that guy over there took it away
from you I mean he took your stuff away
and that creates a bitterness and an
anger and there's also a sense that that
can translate into victimhood I'm a
victim would you ever like to be a
victim my I do not want to be a victim
don't you think it's very easy
particularly if you have other people
around that want to be a victim now I'm
not going to condemn them but it's easy
to fall into that if somebody tells you
you don't have something because
somebody else took it so what we need to
do is if you were to go to say
Youngstown Ohio they talk about that a
lot of international news and I was a
steelworker or I worked in a coal mine
in West Virginia or whatever we have in
Ohio working with with one of the tech
companies we have a list of all the job
openings okay now if you're a victim and
I come to you and I say you are coal
miner or you're steel worker and this
would be hard for me so listen I can
show you this internet stuff right and I
can get you one of these jobs you don't
have to become an expert but I can show
you stuff if I'm a victim I may not want
to do it but if I if I give that person
a message Hey look at these jobs it pays
good money your family will be helped
help will be healthier your children
will be healthier you will have more
self-respect but you know it's tough
where you are I understand is the better
message then well you're just a victim
and we're gonna go and punish people
right that's I don't know it doesn't
work for the good for the mental health
of our society yeah so I mean that's a
great phrase right there cuz we seem to
be in a mental I just came up with it
that's pretty good you're right don't go
back and hey roll the tape they should
roll the tape yeah we're long past there
I'm sorry tape there's no tape anymore
so but- pop and get the electrons back
sorry no no so negative populism did you
see that train coming because it's yummy
that that Trump grabbed it as a
manifestation he's not he didn't create
this people for a long time have felt at
rich get richer and the poor get poor
people in my party have ignored that may
be to some degree early on I did too I
thought well what's that all about
but it's true that you see these chasms
and those are dangerous hmm because you
know we need to believe that all this
wealth and everything changes they say
that the ocean always kind of flips
upside down and that's what we need to
see in our country that you know people
on the bottom can get to the top and we
look at Bezos guy selling books out of
his garage yeah look at you it's just a
matter of time till you're a billionaire
you know yeah you you know he's
delivering me a lot of stuff every day
but you see what I'm saying I mean it is
possible to rise in a free society with
a free enterprise and do you think we
stopped selling that correctly because I
don't think we talked about it yeah that
young people now they starting to think
that socialism is cool yeah I don't I
don't get that i mean well cuz it sounds
good you know like let's share I can
tell you a really interesting story yeah
my chief of staff there's that you know
that show that you get on your phone at
nine o'clock Eastern it's like they ask
questions and you answer them my kids
have done it for a while they don't do
it anymore I don't know what what the
show is called well anyway she and her
kids two daughters they listen to this
every every night at nine o'clock and
they work together and so she said one
day to her kids why don't I I'll be on
one phone and you got you'll be on your
phone and and joy you'll be on your
phone and let's have a competition
they looked at her like she was crazy
they're like why would we do that you
know so you know when I guess what I'm
saying about that is the idea of
community and together is good but we
don't want that to erode the basic sense
that competition is good as long as it's
played fairly yes and everybody has a
chance to compete so really what you're
talking about you're sort of talking
about individualism and how we can
create groups around that as opposed to
collectivism right yeah really the
thrust of this write that down that's a
good one individual and collective ISM
but if you're a young person you go I
don't know what's wrong with that
but but look there my hope because they
would rather take a job that pays less
if the job has meaning look at what
they're doing in parkland look at what
these young people are doing across this
country and using social media to have a
voice I mean it's it's really awesome I
mean it's it gets me really pumped up ya
see I think we need a new era of
activism and citizenship and by the way
we're wheats fixate all the time on the
leader okay
did you see that movie on Churchill a
darkest hour I didn't see it yet I just
saw a lot of him in the crowd why don't
you doing Gary Oldman I know I gotta get
out there it's time to man now I'll do
it tonight I'm giving you my word
now I'm oh you have my word yeah anyway
here's the thing I'm watching it tonight
in that movie and this is made-up stuff
he gets on he gets goes down and gets on
the subway and he's talking to people
and they're like you we're not giving in
and they they they embolden him set the
fire in him I'm not telling you that
that he wasn't a great leader because he
clearly he was but it was a bottom up
and a top down I mean when we think
about the civil rights movement I mean
they didn't the the great leaders Martin
Luther King Day me get help
politicians were afraid of him including
JFK they were all afraid of him
and what happened it was it was from the
street up a lot of social change the end
of the Vietnam War how much longer would
the generals have said we were winning
and by the way look at Afghanistan they
keep saying old word victories just to
cut the corner yeah terrible and so you
have a situation here where you can't
just expect change in the country
because I have elected a good I have a
new good coach so therefore I'm going to
win a basketball game it doesn't work
that way it works both ways yeah good
leader but a great group of people that
drive you know the drive change
how dangerous then is that cult of
personality that we've now made around
the president and I'm not just talking
about Trump here I mean even with Obama
and plenty of the other presidents that
we think that somehow the executive
branch is one person is going to fix it
well you know there's a book that I I
don't know that I'm like I don't have a
lot of things up here I'm getting your
life book might be okay go the book is
not here it is a book that says this and
I have never talked about this before
like on television I was with a great
preacher got 6,000 people he's in the
Silicon Valley he's very grace oriented
and hopeful and he's just he's a PhD and
psychology he's just got all this stuff
all this talent and I was asking him I
said I keep telling people it's bottom
up not top down
he said well John it's interesting
because a man wrote a book and the book
says that when pieces of our society
start to erode let's think about it
Facebook Wells Fargo
Equifax you know the scandal around
around Volkswagen sports you've got guys
that you know got had brain injuries but
the league isn't helping them and
they're living in a car the families are
destitute or Hollywood we need to say
anything there yeah you look across the
board and we're seeing an erosion of
what we really want right so there is a
tendency this man maintains that I'm
fascinated to read this book that we now
start looking to politics to solve these
problems in other words we look at
politicians or government to use in a
sense coercion to restore things to the
right balance and it just doesn't work
that way really in practicality now I'm
the governor of the state seventh
largest state I've it's a very powerful
executive position but I can't just give
heed extermo pare and expect it to work
the people have to be engaged and assent
and do things they have to self-govern
they have the lifts and so this is a
very very I think this
like the next thing to think about to me
it's the next wave you know what I love
what I think has been fun because of my
friends and because of the my mind in a
way it works I'm kind of always looking
for the next thing and I can kind of
sense the next thing you know and I
believe this is something that really
needs to be talked about I mean it's
virtue its religion it's doing well by
doing good it's driving ourselves from
the bottom up it's not trying to vest
all this power and a handful of people
in the government because I think it's
futile yeah I hate to tell you this but
in a weird way you don't sound like a
politician but I think you could take
that as a cop
no I'm look I'm a public official I'm a
CEO of a state I'm sick of politics
drives me crazy because I see that in
the middle of trying to do things we're
all weak we're all everybody's weak and
we're all susceptible to certain
pressures you know and and I'm like we
need to run through that door and
they're like oh no no no no no who's
slow down here you know and all that
kind of stuff and it's it's here's the
problem with politics you know you could
sit next to somebody your entire
lifetime in an office job and never
really know what they think but in
politics people get called out mm-hmm
it's really interesting they get called
out and it's in some ways it's not fair
because it's almost like an x-ray like
you know you and I could know each other
we could hang out we could watch
basketball games and never ever get into
my finding out how you make decisions in
a really tough situation but with
politics you're gonna have to vote and
if you vote wrong you're afraid you're
gonna lose I mean it really it really is
an amazing process and it's frustrating
my my friend and former guests a couple
times Eric Weinstein he's a
world-renowned mathematician and also an
thinker and all sorts that he talked
about how one of the things we've lost
now is communal sense making that
because everything has become so
politicized sports are politicized now
Hollywood as you just mentioned that all
of these things have become so political
but what does that mean I don't
that what does that turn well so for
example like you know everything that
happened with the kneeling about the
aisle anthem that we start that if you
turn on SportsCenter you're watching
politics if you turn on the news and
they're talking about Hollywood it's
about sex can but it's politics or is
that a discussion of virtue or values is
it politics you know well I guess it's
some level it's both right on the
underlying piece of debate about
behavior mm-hmm it's behavior it's not
really politics no I understand what
that person would be saying I'm not sure
that's the right characterization so
yeah you're right on ESPN you know it's
a lot of you know there's a lot of angst
over there now because of different
positions but really kind of debating
how we're supposed to behave don't you
think yeah
well that's what we're doing now what
was so amazing about the kneeling it was
brought about by the the guy that played
for the 49ers people didn't know this I
was told this you need a devout
Christian yeah Colin Kaepernick when
people hear that they're like whoa you
know isn't it interesting that when we
dig in to somebody who we feel one way
or another about it's amazing sometimes
how we find out things that change our
fundamental attitude towards them did
you find that that whole situation
actually was what was right about
America in a bizarre way I found that
everybody was screaming about here's
what I here's what he was doing in jail
and everywhere all but here's what I
think where it got lost yeah I don't
feel that the players themselves were
able to articulate to Americans exactly
why they were doing that and exactly
what they wanted I think was kind of
lost in the motion as opposed to what
Israel what's behind this you know what
is really behind this you know I'm a
black man and I've warned my kid that be
careful about when you're out there late
at night and what you might find I think
if people heard that and they understood
that they would say oh so that was the
one way you had to say something because
it's so divided the country now you know
and people had different views but you
know what I
Dave what I have found in my life is if
you pull people together like we have on
police and community a tough issue I
just had two police officers killed
murdered in my little hometown in Ohio
you heard about it happened a couple
weeks ago community needs to understand
that mom and dad need to go home at
night you know they they're at risk they
you go to a domestic disturbance and you
have to go in a door you you are putting
your life on the line community needs
understand it but police need to
understand that if you're it that they
need and that community if you're not
treating people right in the community
you're gonna have a problem sit them
down the bet peel to the better angels
and in many cases you can come up with
resolutions but you have to get the
right people in a room and you have to
appeal to the better angels in them yeah
I suspect you don't think Trump is
appealing to better angels hey that
seems to be pretty no I mean I think
that you know look my job on this is to
my job I have a position a platform I
can say things I'm not here to be you
know knee-jerk against Trump if he does
a good thing he should be praised and if
he does something that's dividing us
then I can't support it to the point
where I didn't even go to the convention
in my state or ever endorsed him I
wasn't like weaseling around I would say
that's the wrong word I wasn't
maneuvering around to say okay one day I
liked him and the next day I did and I
just was consistent look I took a lot of
heat for it the amount of pressure that
you must have got from the party and
from pressure what is pressure pressure
whether they say pressure is a guy that
loses his job and got a couple kids to
feed that's pressure pressure in
politics what are they gonna do to me
you know what they're gonna criticize me
make you know what do you we talked
about mean briefly just now about the
the anthem part what do you make of the
state of race in America if you listen
to a lot of people right now it seems
like we're at the worst racial state
that we know I think you know I think
we've made a lot of progress I I do I
think though that what we're seeing now
is it's back to this I don't want
somebody getting something that I don't
get and somebody else took what I have
and why doesn't anybody care about me
and I think that caring about me is real
Dave I do
let's say that you that you have a kid
and you need and you need a pill to deal
with that kids problem but it's
expensive and you can't get it does
anybody stand up for you you know if
this is where people feel like and this
is where community matters you know the
if I'm if if I'm being harassed at work
how about that story in the New York
Times where these waitresses we're being
told let me grope you and I'll give you
a $20 tip I mean who in that restaurant
saw that and said I'm gonna take you
outside right to the guy that was the
perpetrator
people tend to feel I think too much of
the time that we're in this alone neck
cut doesn't that kind of get back to the
overstate this but back to the texting
and the no communication we got a care
about our neighbor the way our neighbor
cares about us weird I learned that from
my mother you know tell you interesting
story my mother I we would hang out at
the school all the time and there's the
kids came up and gave us pony rides and
my mother wanted to check out what is
this whole thing going on up there so
she comes up and i don't i was probably
a dime to do a pony ride and and my
mother was there and she gave the guy
that had the pony a lot more money than
the cost of the pony ride and we were
walking home and i said mom you gave
that guy a lot of money
she said Johnny did you see his eye it
was out of place
we got to help people like that like I
used to see my father given a couple
extra bucks to the guy that picked up
the trash because he didn't make much
money I thanks mom and dad because
that's something you carry all right so
this is interesting because I feel like
I'm talking to half philosopher half
governor here so let's go let's finish
with solutions
I like that by the way half philosopher
half politician Oh governor you said I
have got half governor there we go that
was fun put that on your business yeah
there you go you don't have to credit me
so I want to talk some solutions because
so many things seem wrong in 2016 that I
think that's what's led us here so we
can talk about some of this
so I'm watching the debates that you
were part of they're the dumbest way to
pick a president okay you you can't get
from me no way you can't pick you the
way to do it is now look it's all about
ratings okay so nobody wants to change
the format but the way it ought to be is
what we're doing let people let somebody
interview somebody find out who they are
and then we can judge instead of like
who's got the cleverest line or who you
know it's really stupid yeah when you
were up there in Trump you know usually
he was browbeating everybody and you
could see sort of each debate would go
by and he'd pick who he had to go for
and and you know the media kind of fell
along with that that really wasn't
suited for what you're doing here well
is the field narrowed he just didn't
show up anymore he didn't debate anymore
I mean I wanted him to debate but he'd
towards the end when you stayed it was
now the other guy was down to fewer
fewer of us yeah but I just think it's a
bad way to pick a president now we I
think this all started probably with
Kennedy and Nixon and and Nixon lost
because he looked he didn't you know
have the right brow he was way I mean
what a dumb way to pick pick a leader so
I don't know if that will change I don't
know because it makes too much money for
the network's so what are the things we
can do to just change the electoral
system enough like I'm not somebody that
believes you have to go in and wreck
everything but it seems to me if we
could just tweak some well
gerrymandering needs to be changed so
that we're not gerrymandering is where
you draw a district to favor one party
or the other and then all you have to do
is listen to people and your extreme and
not have to listen to people who are who
are different than you but you need to
be heard that's one thing don't have an
answer for the finance to get the
spending I don't know what to do about
it but I'm open to anything so those are
a couple things is that really the issue
though I mean at the end of the day is
it really if we were just to you know go
backwards with everything I think I
think gerrymandering is very very
serious problem and we are fixing it in
Ohio and I'm proud of my legislature for
doing it that's a big part of it
but isn't a big part of it also the kind
of people we elect you know and do you
carry virtue into these offices and be
willing to take a risk I got a friend of
mine now who's just got on the City
Council and he called me the other day
he said I just seem to be making
everybody mad because they all want to
have this this thing that they want to
do
and I think it's dumb and I said yeah
just just you know pick your battles and
be pleasant and be firm and you know we
shouldn't want to be in these jobs
forever its natural nobody wants to go
to work and lose their job okay nobody
wants to do that
but you're not in these jobs for a you
know for a long time I don't think you
should be yeah at the end of the day is
that really what the government's role
is is just making sure we have jobs I
mean really you know making sure we're
basically secure I think it's a greatest
moral purpose is is to provide an
environment for job creation because
that's what creates human dignity right
that's what strengthens communities and
builds strength and families you know
for the government of the United States
make sure that we have we are protected
you know that we can be free and yet
safe and then it's also course domestic
tranquility you know that we're at peace
where we are so if you have high
unemployment and it's terrible so I
believe our greatest moral purpose as
politician for me and my job is the fact
that I need to have a job creating
environment so it's interesting as I'm
listening to you I can understand the
the reasons for not liking Trump and the
tweets and I you know the virtue and and
all of that I can get that in terms of
policy of the things that he's done well
let's talk about a couple things you
know let's talk about immigration I mean
the idea that we're going to ship these
daca kids out to me is one but we're I
don't even know where the Democrats are
we keep talking about Trump I mean we're
into Democrats is Bart is Bernie and his
left-wing philosophy is that were I
don't know where the Democrats are but
this daca thing should be solved I mean
these are these are people you know 25
26 27 years old
they came here when they were six or
seven or eight now we're gonna ship them
out there in the meaningful part of our
culture so what do you actually do then
what what they ought to let be
grandfathered in they ought to be said
you get to stay and then when it comes
to immigration itself we need to know
who's coming and we need to be able to
protect our borders but I don't want to
be shrinking legal immigration I think
people create a great deal to our
country you know trade you know it's a
thorny issue but 40 million Americans
have trade related jobs and most of
those businesses that are involved in
exporting or small and medium-sized
businesses and consumers benefit from
open and free now if it's not open
free find and have a process to restore
equity but just don't go out to create a
trade war you know I mean those are
things what else you want to ask about I
mean those are two the jump at me
there's lots of them yeah well I throw a
couple others out we actually did meet
once before it was at I believe it was
the first or second Republican debate
and I asked you a question in the Phaedo
with everyone's jamming my strong enough
words we're jamming their microphones in
Wi-Fi you sir trust me I had to fight
through plenty of people to get the
question but basically at my question to
you was that the social issues that gay
marriage in particular I could tell you
I think in the first debate you
immediately said they asked you about it
and you said that's not what I want to
focus on well I think I can't remember
exactly what I said but it did get it
you know look I I it's not I'm not
that's not where I want to live because
that is a dividing I mean in terms of
gay marriage I'm fine with it I mean I
think it was that time when I said I was
going to a wedding of my of my gate you
know one of my gay friends who's
terrific and I talked to him all the
time yeah I don't even think that way
it's yeah that's behind it's beyond us
so you'd love for the Republicans to get
past the social stuff right I mean I
think in effect the party has even even
the more conservative Christian side of
the party isn't talking about it that
and I got on here Sam Laura Murphy has
to be really rally tolerance and it's
you know things have changed and you
know I prefer the traditional marriage
but you know I'm not like I don't worry
what you're doing you know you mentioned
to me it's your 21st anniversary with
your wife today look exactly and I'm
here I here you are with me what does
that say I don't know what that says
where you on medical marijuana or
legalization in general I'm not for
legalizing it because it get look I told
people when I was in college of course I
smoked dope I mean we all did virus a we
all did but many of us did but here's
the problem
you can't tell kids don't do drugs oh by
the way this drugs okay so it's a
problem medical marijuana we have it in
our state and we have it in our state
but I don't think legalizing it is is a
good thing to do
yeah is this one of those things where
so when I hear that to me this is where
my libertarian side we're picking and I
would say well you can
put anything in your body that you want
and as long as you're in the privacy of
your own home and the rest of that
argument makes a lot of sense to me but
you think that if we just sort of unfurl
this that I just say I got kids here I
mean we got an opiate crisis I mean you
know I just was looking last night you
got fentanyl in these street drugs
whether it's coke or or heroin and
they're just dropping dead you know left
and right this is not a time when I
think we ought to be trying to say to
kids okay what don't do any drugs but
you know but this one's okay to do
that's kind of how I feel about it yeah
and yet you know alcohol I mean ya know
and we look and we have a lot of people
die from drunk driving and all that but
we'd been through that and I don't know
where this is all going to ultimately
end up I'm just giving you my cents
dealing with a real problem here I don't
want to have to explain to young people
that too you know well you can do this
but don't do that it needs to be a
simple message for me yeah okay couple
more and then the big question at the
end so the big question at the end I
don't know what I'm gonna do in 2020 I
don't know what I'm gonna do I really
don't know I am I want to be able to
participate in a positive way in the
public debate that's I want my voice to
be out there and that's kind of what I
want to do and I don't know where that's
gonna take me I'm not plotting or
scheming but I'm making a lot of effort
to be able to have the resources to be
able to stay all options are really on
the table but I don't know what what
will be exercised because we don't know
what the future is gonna bring the big
question was gonna be whether you wanted
to play golf with me after this but do
you play are you a good golfer not well
but I write well
okay swell all right that was the answer
to that question a couple other things
okay so you're in California right now I
know you just met with Arnold
Schwarzenegger
you guys are talking about how to reset
Californians in polity I'm here in
California it's an insanely high tax
state you know if I told you what my
property tax is on this place your head
would explode I should probably move to
Ohio if you want to help her well my
property taxes are high enough it makes
my head explode drivin in my state yeah
trust me in LA yeah what do you think
can be done to help a place like
California that's obviously so less I
traditionally Japanese those you're
beginning to lose people yeah you know
whether it's to Washington State no
income tax
Nevada or to Austin Texas I mean it's
you don't want to see that happening you
got to make government more efficient
you remember in the old days when you
bought a Kindle you know you had to pay
money for it now they'll pay you to have
it get out right now I mean if we need
to use creative and and 21st century
technology and techniques the skinny the
government down to get it to do what
it's supposed to do and be efficient and
effective you just said you can't
believe what it was like for me to get
permission to build a studio in my
garage
no that's nuts this is the 21st century
what are they worried about yeah
and so you know I think that and I love
California
I mean are you kidding me I wanted to be
out here I wanted to campaign out here
but things move too fast I mean how
could you not love this state but you
can also do enough things to begin to
drive people and businesses out and that
it's not good all right well since you
answered the big one already I'll just
give you a wide one to bring us home
with which would be so many emails that
I get and tweets and messages that I get
are all about people that are just
afraid look can I go back well for one
second because you were asking about
like these social issues okay mm-hmm I
read an article about Billy Graham who
was who spoke to 200 million people
across the globe and he had fights with
people inside of faith because he stayed
away from the hot button social issues
of the time I think it is possible for
example I'm dealing with guns right now
okay and I have brought a group of
people together to mediate that I think
you can deal with these social issues by
being in a position of bringing people
together at the end you may have to walk
away from the table but I admire what
Billy Graham said there's so much
negativity in the world today why don't
I like Billy Graham did why don't I just
focus on the on the positive things the
uplifting things instead of dragging
yourself down into these ditches where
we just go into you know warfare with
you know world war one war for trench
warfare it's not gonna help us in the
long run those issues can be dealt with
in a way and on the edges but at the end
let
try to lift our culture Kasich 2020
politician Oh what is it philosophers /
governor I see I like that I see it all
coming together right so the final one
though is that I get all of these
messages and tweets and emails from
people that are afraid to get involved
they're just afraid to say what they
think be either because of political
correctness or the way it's gonna affect
their job or their friends I don't think
you're obviously out there you're you're
clearly not afraid to say what you think
as I said there was no preparation you
sat down and we did this for an hour
what would you say to those young people
that want to I mean life is short and
life is also a journey you've got to
listen to your conscience and sometimes
it's hard sometimes when you stand up
sometimes you might lose something but
in the long run you'll be admired and
leave an indelible impression for
showing courage have people around you
that you can talk these things through
because you know just doing it all
yourself leads to self righteous
behavior that is not always very pretty
but at the end look yourself in the
mirror look yourself in the mirror and I
happen to believe that there's a world
yet to come that's really no how am I
going into that one huh but there's a
world yet to come and I think our
actions here prepare us for that world
and it's going to be okay that's how you
ended an interview for more on Governor
Kasich check out John Kasich
[Music]
you